What do you see as the three biggest issues
facing Brisbane?
The biggest issue is housing
the second biggest issue is definitely transport
the third big issue is really that question of
sustainable development and and,
and preparing for global warming
definitely traffic congestion,
uh, cost of living, uh,
also housing
obviously public
transport is a massive issue in and around the city
on population growth, uh,
how big is too big for Brisbane?
Population growth has been a constant
thing for Brisbane for a long time
as long as it continues to enhance our lifestyle
and it's a good thing
the point where people see it
taking away from the lifestyle,
obviously they'll be challenges
and so I see growth as a challenge and an opportunity
um, but in terms of how big is too big, uh, look,
I think if we,
if we get the planning right,
um, plenty of more people can live in Brisbane
you can't just say
we're gonna cut numbers at this point right?
We need to make sure that our
infrastructure and all of our networks and everything
grow in just one step ahead of our population growth
a lot of people are concerned about population
growth because of traffic congestion impacts
but if we have better public transport,
we can accommodate, um,
a much larger population
so people present
population growth as a single problem and say, well,
what is the optimal
number of people who live in the city
and the Answer is
it depends. It depends
how much public transport infrastructure can we get?
How much screen space we
can we accommodate?
What's more important to you?
Service delivery or keeping rates low?
If people see their value for their money,
then they're not, you know,
rates doesn't become so much of an issue.
I would like to see rates
increase more than what a CPI increase would be
because obviously
it's really important to keep down
with pressure on rates.
But I think people reach a point where
if they see that they're getting value for money,
then there's less complain,
complaining about the rates.
I think there's a false dichotomy between
improving service delivery and keeping rates low
because the Green's
position is that we can dramatically
improve the services that the council provides
and the projects that invest in
without increasing rates.
For ordinary residents
in this current climate,
it's gonna be keeping rates low.
I think, you know,
obviously, we are a service delivery organisation,
but we can only provide what we can
afford to provide. Right now,
it's gonna be affordability.